hello, how are you,
I'm here directly from são paulo to
communicate a great news from
the google cloud platform universe
my name is ricardo and i help companies
in brazil to migrate to google
audio our team works in cases such as
sulamérica that uses solutions such as
happy end in which 58 story to create
innovative applications in a
hybrid environment of high scalability and
performance another interesting case is that
of contabilizei, a startup provides
accounting services to small and
medium-sized companies across the country and runs
all its highly
scalable infrastructure within gcp  using
services such as google container end and
be with it the new region of são paulo
will allow customers to process and
store their data in brazil this
means consistent gains in
speed for all our customers
in the region performance tests
demonstrate and 50 95 per  percent
latency reduction when serving customers
across south america c  Compared to
any region of the united states,
google cloud is continually making
investments in infrastructure and
services for its businesses whether they are
in argentina, colombia, chile,
peru or brazil, however we are
more than eager to see what our
customers will create and  build with the
arrival of our region
thank you very much